good morning everyone this is a very
exciting day for Carnegie Mellon
University and for I hope for Yahoo as
well to take a relationship that's
always been very strong between our two
organizations and take it a big step
further and with a really exciting new
project so just his background Yahoo
he's been a very strong contributor to
both our education and our research
efforts for quite a few years and just
decide a few examples
they got us going we were very
interested in what's now referred to as
Big Data starting in about 2007 and we
formed a partnership with Yahoo that
gave us access to a set of machines they
had available and it really kicked off
some major research including Tom
Mitchell's nelle project which is at the
core of what we're going to start
talking about today so they've also
delivered a 432 server machines in a big
purple moving van once a few years ago
out there that really helped us put some
computing capacity within our
information lab in the Heinz College as
well as in the computer science program
that really helped us with resources
they've been generous with support via
graduate fellowships making data
available in various forms for us to be
able to do research and so and at many
levels supporting student activities
down to the level of we've got a big
purple ping-pong table in our one of our
labs so Yahoo's a great company and
we're very proud to be part of it and as
I mentioned we've had these connections
but today we're going to take a big step
forward with a collaborative research
project on mobile applications and what
they can provide in a very proactive way
with access to information which we're
calling this project the in mind project
so I'd like to introduce
Ron Brockman who's a vice president from
Yahoo who all described more about what
this will be about Ron Thank You Randy
welcome everybody thank you very much
for being here with us this morning
I want to strongly endorse what randy
said this is a very exciting day for us
at Yahoo as well we've been anticipating
this day for quite some time I'm putting
together what we think are some very
compelling ideas and some plans and to
see it finally come to fruition is very
very satisfying and very exciting for us
so very briefly if you've been following
Yahoo at all recently you're aware that
the one of the major emphases of the
company is around what we call
personalization creating inspiring and
entertaining services for all of our
hundreds of millions of users around the
world and trying to make them the most
interesting most appealing and most
engaging services by knowing enough
about those users that we can satisfy
their interests at the right time and in
the right place also we've had a recent
and very strong continuing emphasis on
mobile uses of our services and we're
bringing those two things here together
in a way in this collaborative effort
with Carnegie Mellon so overall what
we're about to start is a five-year ten
million dollar program that's really a
very strong collaboration between the
two institutions in the past like many
other companies we've given money we've
given servers and other things to the
University but in some ways this is a
lot more appealing because it's really
an intellectual coupling between the two
institutions Tom Mitchell whom you'll
hear from in a moment and I spent a lot
of time together over the years
associated for a long time with the
artificial intelligence community and
triple AI some DARPA work that we did
together which was very very exciting
very important and so this really feels
like the next very large step in a
journey toward sort of a grand dream of
the far-flung future where computers
will work in very close
partnership with humans in ways that are
very natural anticipating what people
want at the right time and in the right
place I'm being very responsive to
request being able to deal with
ambiguity and uncertainty and also being
very supportive and friendly rather than
perhaps intimidating so we're very
excited to start this journey together
today the program which Tom will talk a
little bit more about involves multiple
elements one is something that we might
call a mobile toolkit and this we
believe certainly for Yahoo and perhaps
elsewhere is unprecedented where we are
creating a software package that will
allow faculty and students at Carnegie
Mellon to use real Yahoo service
infrastructure and to create imaginative
new versions of services and things
we've never dreamed of that they can
experiment with here on campus both
internally at the University and with us
in partnership and this is very exciting
for both of us it allows students whom
we'd love to work with later in their
careers as well as faculty to get access
to in a sense the real thing
real services real data not artificial
packages created for classroom
pedagogical use this is great for for us
and we hope it will be great for for
Carnegie Mellon another element of the
program or a series of fellowships we'll
call them Yahoo fellowships they will go
to faculty and students over a sustained
period of time which is also very
important ingredient here because it's
one thing to give gifts that last for a
year or a number of months but the kind
of work that we do that's really looking
far out over the horizon really takes a
long committed effort so in fact these
fellowships will last as long as the
graduate students need them and they
will lead to we hope collaborative work
where students and faculty come and
visit us at our labs most likely in
California and in New York but perhaps
elsewhere and many of our wonderful
Yahoo scientists and engineers will come
and spend time on campus here there are
other elements of this that we can talk
about over
but what I'd like to emphasize is that
this is a in some sense for both of us a
very big thing we don't like to do
things small you know the scale at which
who operates you know the the size of
our customer population Carnegie Mellon
in their own way have done the same
thing creating the world's first machine
learning department so we want to
continue to do very big things together
very dramatic things and not only
provide great opportunities for students
and faculty and our scientists and
engineers but for all of the consumers
and advertisers who will eventually use
future Yahoo products so thank you all
again for being here we're very excited
a few moments to answer your questions
but first let me introduce Tom the head
of the machine learning department
thanks Ron on behalf of myself and also
my co-director Justine Cassell I want to
just start by thanking Yahoo for this
very generous gift and opportunity to do
something really exciting together in
particular I want to thank Ron and Don
McGill and who let's just say did heroic
work to help make this happen this is
really an unprecedented gift in the
history of the machine learning
department and also in the history of
the human-computer interaction Institute
which Justine heads we've never had this
kind of magnitude of gift in our entire
history and it's going to make a very
significant difference in terms of the
life of our graduate students who are
trying to do research and the whole type
of work that we can do so it's not just
unprecedented in terms of the funding
involved but it's also a game-changer in
terms of the style of research so
perhaps some of you don't have this
experience but imagine for a moment that
you're a university faculty member
interested in doing research of the type
that Ron just described trying to invent
new approaches that might be in the
software campaign
of our future you want to do this a
typical life of a faculty member is that
you might write a proposal let's say to
the National Science Foundation and you
might get funding for supporting two
students and maybe part-time for
yourself and then if you think about
that it's really impossible to do under
those circumstances realistic research
that can be embedded in a realistic
scenario if you have some idea about
software to try out say in a mobile
device just you and your two students
don't have the infrastructure for doing
that so this is a game changer this new
Yahoo collaboration is a game changer
for us at the University it rewrites
what becomes possible for us to do and
what we're going to do with this project
is we're going to not just take
individual faculty in there to students
and plug them into the ability to
piggyback on Yahoo's software mobile
toolkit for which I have to thank Scott
Gaffney for coming up with that idea but
in addition we're going to draw together
the research of not just one faculty and
two students but we're going to
cherry-pick
across the entire university the most
relevant research in computer perception
how to make sense of microphone and
camera signals and learning how to do
personalization in human factors and
design and interfaces in the human
computer inner
humming computer interaction Institute
for example and by pulling these
together we'll be able to put together a
kind of prototype system filled it on
top of and surrounding Yahoo's
infrastructure and we're going to have a
concerted effort to sign-in opt-in users
on the CMU campus many of the students
for example to be living in this testbed
this research testbed
so the point I will I really want you to
carry from this is that this is
unprecedented not just in the magnitude
of funding which it is we're very
grateful for that but it also it just
changes the style of research that we're
going to be able to do so we're very
excited to get started and I just want
to before I sit down point out that
Justine is going to give a more detailed
talk about some of the scientific
techniques and the technologies and the
ongoing research here at CMU that we're
going to be building on she'll be giving
that top upstairs after this session
breaks up so at this point I think we'd
like to open up for questions and on
vite Ronon well we have had for some
time an ongoing relationship with Yahoo
Yahoo has provided us as Randy mentioned
hardware infrastructure but also
fellowships for our students in the past
and Don McGill in our campus
representative from Yahoo I'm looking
for done was we were chatting one day
and Don surfaced the idea of doing
something big different from these
piecemeal things we had done before and
so following up on that a lot of
discussions over a substantial period of
time it kind of came together I was
gonna balance out a little bit from our
perspective I'm not sure if it's
terribly well known but in a sense
science really powers a lot of Yahoo's
current product suite and it's very much
we anticipate it's got a major factor
innovation in the future and while we
have a tremendous set of great
scientists around the world we know that
there are a lot more excellent people
elsewhere and especially in the Academy
around the world and so what we've
always done in our Yahoo labs context is
is outreach of various sorts to key
universe
cities we like to work as much as we can
in the open we publish we participate in
international forums and the like and so
the idea of in some sense multiplying
our intelligence around problems like
this by partnering with great
institutions was kind of a natural thing
to do and once the first idea sort of
took root we started talking about what
we might do together then it was pretty
easy to imagine how it would benefit
both institutions and how we could do
something as Tom said that was really
quite big know Carnegie Mellon is I'll
have to have them quote statistics for
you but to our minds Carnegie Mellon is
the preeminent academic institution in
the world in machine learning the scale
of the faculty the interaction between
the computer science department and the
statistics department the people they've
been able to hire the quality of the
students are second to none and this
whole idea of personalization has many
parts to it including information
gathering and analysis and natural
language understanding like but at the
core it's really about learning it's
about taking raw data that's generated
from the real world either intentionally
given to you or observed and drawing
interesting generalizations and
conclusions from it and so the guts of
what we need to do is a personalization
company really focuses around machine
learning so the match was just in some
sense a no-brainer the best institution
in the fields that we care about the
most strong relationship before hand
along many dimensions as both Randi and
Tom have pointed out kind of a long
history of personal relationships
between many of the principles on both
sides here so it was to be honest we
didn't think of any other university do
it with this was this was sort of a
natural first and last thing we thought
of doing in terms of this particular
scale of collaboration
I'm not sure what what so we can talk
about here or not there's a there's a
contract a large one signed after a lot
of great work I have to say amongst two
very active legal teams and we found we
found really great common ground I I
don't even know exactly the details but
universities especially institutions
that have complex funding of their own
and support students of all sorts and
private corporations like ours each have
kind of at the base slightly different
needs around intellectual property but
our folks working together found some
really interesting kind of joint ground
in which they could work and so the
arrangement ends up allowing Carnegie
Mellon to do exactly what it needs with
all the intellectual property that it
creates I guess I could put it that way
and I think that was very important to
both parties and in our case on the
Yahoo side were most excited really
about the collaboration and IP
specifically was not really the point of
this so in fact I think we worked out a
really perhaps a role model working
relationship I don't know certainly if
we do other big things with this
institution and we have a very firm
foundation for building on top of that
and part of our hope is to make lots of
other universities quite jealous so
we'll see how that works
it's a great question thank you
it's interestingly enough it may not be
apparent to many of our users but a
version of this kind of personalization
is out there already in many of our
products so if you take the Yahoo
homepage and I don't know the exact
statistics but it certainly visited by
literally hundreds of millions of people
around the world there are various
elements on the page that are already
created with at least assistance from
machine learning algorithms and in fact
what what we we think of as the infinite
stream of articles that you see either
on the home page or many of our other
important sites like Yahoo News Yahoo
Sports Yahoo Finance those streams are
already personalized to the users who
sign in and let us know who they are and
have given us information about what
they like and don't like in different
ways so in fact it's you can't really
tell in some ways but if you're finding
yourself spending more time on those
pages and clicking on more articles and
being more engaged with what we do
you're already being served by
personalization technology and the
secret of course is to do it well for
every individual that that visits us and
everyone is different using information
from those individuals using social
information using popularity that comes
with sort of the broad population and
mixing them all together to provide this
really engaging experience so that's
that's the key place where will we will
start and then if you think about mobile
activity
an awful large percentage very large
percentage of the things that people do
every day with smartphones including
mail and search and checking the weather
dealing with sports scores fantasy
sports finance etc are major offerings
from Yahoo and so the idea is that we
want to provide in the long run this
multifaceted kind of unified experience
where you are when you need it on
devices of various form factors
they could be phones they could be
tablets they could be devices that have
yet been unanticipated in fact one of
the great things about Carnegie Mellon
are some really interesting work going
on here about novel ways for people to
carry services around with them that
don't look like smartphones or tablets
so we're very excited about that and the
idea there is also then to accommodate
your interests and needs and your
desires and wishes where you are under
whatever circumstance you find yourself
with whatever kind of device you're
using and if we do it right you'll just
find yourself more and more engaged and
really delighted by the services and not
even stop to think about how is this
happening or even being asked to do
anything overt to indicate to our
systems what you like and dislike
the best predictor of future behavior is
what's happening here on the campus yes
the the idea of learning to personalize
this based on data and therefore a key
part of the research here is going to
involve privacy issues and how to do
that data collection processing in a way
that optimizes personal privacy
experimentation sort of living
laboratory people will need to opt in
you to overtly say yes it is okay to use
my data certain kinds of data in
exchange hopefully further research
value as well as that we hope
increasingly personalized experience so
we start with very was a direct opt-in
system for this experimental facility